Joe Biden skipped the 911 memorial today
and he's the first president to do so uh
it's shocking and I gotta pick a police
I'm I'm personally offended by that
there's this really great story that I
want to we'll talk about when we get
into when we get into this about a man
who sacrificed his life and there were
many many people who sacrificed their
lives but not only in the short term by
running back and into those buildings to
save people
the people who are doing cleanup after
the fact who had permanent lung damage
and cancer and and injuries and they
risked everything on that day to save as
many people as possible so the least
you'd think a president could do is just
be there in New York to say that you
know this this means something to us but
he didn't and uh that's that's just
offensive